hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
using multiplex immunofluorescence to
predict clinical outcomes in solid tumor
cancer
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by ecoya biosciences
to learn more visit akoyabio.com
encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
alban based ceo of
explicit aban you may now begin your
presentation
so hi everybody and
thanks for the nice introduction
also i want to thank the organizer for
giving me for giving me the opportunity
to present
the work that has been convicted
in cooperation with the teams from
institute bargaining in bordeaux and
institute gustavo rossi
in paris as well as with the sandro de
rocher de cordelli
and astrazeneca
so the work i will present
today has been recently published and is
dealing about the evaluation of presence
of mature tertiary lymphoid structure as
a predictive biomarker for any
checkpoint
blockade response
and this work
has been achieved thanks to a
new technology so a multi-text
immunohisto fluorescence approach
so here on my disclosures i'm a
shareholder of explicit so a company
working as a contract research
organization in the field of immune
oncology
so i will discuss today about cancer
immunotherapy which is a
clear paradigm shift so while most of
the cytotoxic agent has been
developed to target directly to tumor
cells cancer immunotherapy aim
at reinvigorating the immune immune
systems to finally
uh and use tumor cell death by by the
immune by the immune cells
in the nineteenth the first evidence of
cancer immunotherapy
efficacy has been obtained
thanks to the use of high dose of il2
for the treatment of metastatic
melanoma which demonstrated
unprecedented response
but with some limitation this treatment
is effective only in a small fraction of
patients and also is associated with
significant
toxicity though so at this at this time
cancer immunotherapy was not
was not the pass forward and we had to
wait uh several years of intensive uh
research efforts
to uh
to the until the discovery of immune
checkpoint
and immune checkpoint blocker and start
the immunology revolution era
so 10 years
10 years ago approximately
metastatic melanomas the treatment of
metastatic melanoma has been
considerably
change thanks to the use of immune
checkpoint inhibitor so namely
epididymimab but
mostly with nivolumab and the
combination of both which derive
really impressive clinical response as
you can see with with with tail
on the curve and with a
strong improvement of median survival
so um besides
the use of cancer immunotherapy in the
in the field of melanoma and thanks to
the to the success of this of this
treatment so immunotherapy has been
tested in several other indications with
difference in term of rate of response
according according to the to the cancer
indication
however
while this treatment approach is really
effective it still
remains to be improved in term of rate
of response as most of patients still
die
from from cancer as as they develop
resistance and die
so immune oncology still have
years to to to go
so the current challenge in the immune
oncology field is
the identification of predictive
biomarkers that can allow a better
selection of patients who might respond
to immune checkpoint
blockers and also
remain on the understanding of
resistance mechanism acquired or
secondary that can help to identify
novel
drug
targets
okay so the so i will focus uh the the
talk today on the on the evaluation of
the determinant of response to immune
checkpoint
uh blockers and the previous paradigm
was mostly that the t-cells are the main
cells involved in the response to immune
checkpoint inhibitor but thanks
to a recent seminal work
showing that b cells are also a key
player in response to immunotherapy so
t cells are not only only a key cells b
cells can be
an important and important player
so this work uh these several works was
published
so last year in uh in nature so
demonstrated that uh b cell signature
was associated with an improved uh
response to a new checkpoint uh blockade
in different cancer indications so
namely sarcoma but also melanoma and
renal cancer
so this evidence
was obtained thanks to the
transcriptomic
transphobic analysis approach
and interestingly uh in this in this
paper it was demonstrated that the
patient
for which we found a b-cell signature
was was characterized by the presence of
tertiary
structures so so-called
tls which is a structure that favor
the antigen presentation on t cells by
b cells and that can ultimately favor a
92 more immune immune response
so this tertiary and fluid structure are
organized
with with b cells and surrounded by a t
cell but also with
other key players like follicular
dendritic dendritic cells
so the question we wanted to to answer
is uh is tls the presence of tls at the
immunohistochemistry
level so at the structure level
is associated with response to a immune
checkpoint inhibitor in cancer patient
so as mentioned previously so this work
has been
published recently nature
cancer so thanks to a collaboration with
several
several teams
and so the approach was
was
possible thanks to the availability on a
large court of cancer
on sample from cancer patients so um a
discovery court with
328
cancer samples from patients treated
with immune checkpoint inhibitor and it
was a pump cancer study with a different
type of cancer including of course
lung cancer
so the first step of this study was to
evaluate the presence of tls thanks to a
conventional immunohistochemistry
approach for combining the cd3 and c20 a
marker 33 for t7c 24 b cells and we were
able to uh detect in a third of patients
the presence of tls so 105 patients with
tls and 223 patients without cls
on patient for which we were able to
detect tls we went more in depth to
evaluate the maturity status of this tls
thanks to a multiplex multiplex approach
combining different markers so for
instance cd4 for helper t cells cd8 for
sytotoxic tc24bc21
and cd 23 for the evaluation of the
maturity status
so after evaluation by expert
pathologist we were able to detect in
half of this tell us positive patients
or 58 patients the presence of mature
tls uh while in 47 the the tls were not
considered as as mature and finally
we wanted to evaluate the association of
the presence of mature tls with a
clinical outcome
so the objective response but also the
progression free survival and overall
survival
so before going uh into the
implementation of this large panel on
this large court we wanted
first to
develop and validate this this new panel
so this new panel here combining the
different markers i listed and which are
illustrated here as a multiplex but also
as a monoplex uh staining that
illustrates that a b cell so cd20 are
really surrounded by cd8 t cells for
instance here while cd4 already uh
really rare and that you can and also
you can see that you have some
follicular dendritic cells and material
b
as highlighted by the cd23
marker
so for the validation of this panel we
compare the density of this marker
when they were captured
thanks to the multiplex marker or throw
a monoplex approach and we were able to
demonstrate that the density of this of
the different cells were
similar in both situations and we then
considered
the panel as as validated
so when looking at the association
between mature tls and the clinical
outcome
we were able to demonstrate that patient
with mature tls had a higher rate of
objective response has highlighted here
on the graph on the left
on the left part of the of the slide
with a significant difference and
interestingly what is also important to
to depict is a patient with immature tls
or still presence of tls but in the
immature state has the same rate of
response a patient without ls so meaning
that it's really important to have a
favorable environment within the tls to
uh to uh to elicit an effective
antitumor immune response
so this association between the presence
of materials and clinical outcome is
also evidence here
when you look at patients with a longer
overall survival which were
characterized by the high rate of
presence of mature mature tls
this data were also
reinforced thanks to the
progression-free survival data and the
overall survival data demonstrating a
patient with mature tls have a better
better clinical outcome
so in the field of immune oncology so
the pdl one uh the pdl one statue is an
important is an important marker and we
wanted uh here in this work to evaluate
if
the presence of mature tls
was also associated with a clinical
outcome according to the pdl1 status so
meaning p inpatient with
pdl1 positivity versus spdl1 negativity
so for this purpose we perform
multiplex staining so combining cd8 and
pdl1 so also thanks to an
immunohistochemistry
approach and together with pathologists
there were scoring of this sample so
with the tps
inferior to one percent and with gps
supplier to one percent
um
and on patients uh for which the score
was below one percent we performed the
same multiplex uh panel and we perform
the same
scoring of mature tls and compare again
the clinical outcome to the presence of
jealous
so here it's a
data so from patient with uh
tps below uh one percent and
interestingly what we observe is that
independently of of pdl one
the presence of mature tls was still
associated with
with an objective response with also the
progression-free survival and with
overall
overall survival
we performed the same approach and
looking at the predictive predictive
value of mature tls presence in patients
with
pdl1 positivity so tps superior to one
percent
and again we compare the
the we look at the association between
the
presence of mature tls and the clinical
outcome and as you can see here
the difference is really
impressive as you can observe that
patient
with a mature tls has a really
better objective response despite
the limited size of the of the of the
courts
here
so this is observable thanks to the
objective response but also thanks to
the progression free survival and
overall survival
even this is not significant but again
due to the limited size of the core but
the trends are really really clear
so all together
this this result demonstrates that the
presence of mature tls is associated
with an improved
clinical outcome in conservation
treaties with immunotherapy and this
independently of pdl1
status and so that must be considered
for further
clinical clinical testing
so another
marker that is associated and has been
at least described to be associated with
a clinical
outcome on patients treated by
immunotherapy is the
level of cd8 and filtration
within the tumor and for this purpose
we perform
we perform
[Music]
an analysis so here it's not a cd3 c20
but it's cd8 and pdl1 but we saw we
performed the multiplex
immunohistochemistry
staining
and we performed then an image analysis
that allows us to make tissue
segmentation so in green so
which is not the two most
[Music]
the part which is not the tumor and in
red the two more parts which were then
segmented into cells and then phenotype
into
cd8 positive cells versus d8 and
negative
on this basis we were able to
fortify patients according to the
to the level of cd8 infiltration and we
were able to
separate so patients with cds
cd8 high so 163 patients and the patient
with the cd8 low 165
on this
according to this
two class classes we look at the impact
of the presence of mature tls on the
predictivity
so here is a data
association
with a clinical clinical outcome and in
patients with a high infiltration of cd8
we are able to observe again a good
productivity of
of the presence of mature
tls
as
illustrated here by an improved response
rate in patient with mature tls and also
as observed thanks to the pfs and os
survival curve
in the same way we look at patients with
a low infiltrate of a cd8 and the
results are really uh
does not have the same do not have the
same trend as
there is not major significance
in this fraction of of patient
so it seems
in contrast to the pdl1 status that the
presence of mature tls is mostly
predictive of the clinical outcome in
patients with highly infiltrated cd8
cd82 more
but it's important to note also that a
patient with tls or associated morphe or
associated with a high level of cd8
infiltration that could explain also
this difference in term of predictive
predictive value of the gls
so as a as a biomarker
biomarker studio we wanted to
evaluate the robustness of the of the
approach using validation core so we we
had a chance to have access to two
independent validation core so
validation cost a so
with 131
cancer patient
same treatment
and also pan cancer study
and on which we have we use the same
approach so tls
scoring tls maturity evaluation and
association with a clinical outcome
it's the same design for the second
valid
validation cohort support b
with less cancer patients 81 all treated
with immune checkpoint inhibitor
and same strategy and here i will
present
the clinical
data associated with the presence of of
tls
and here you can you can see that
there is still a predictive value of
this of this marker as asus as
illustrated with objective response the
pfs and the os
the same result was observed for the
second
validation validation
cohort
so all together from this this upfront
this results demonstrate that the
detection of tls
is a robust
biomarker
to predict response to immune checkpoint
inhibitor and at the advantage to be
easy to implement as it relies on
available
available to more samples
in parallel of this work so this the
work that i have that i just present has
been based mostly on the scoring by a
pathologist but we wanted also to look
at the
automation
automation of the of the process thanks
to the image
analysis so this work is currently uh
ongoing and so as you can see so here is
two it's an illustration of two case
with uh detectable uh tls and um
so starting from this from this image so
after slide
digitization
we were able to phenotype all the cells
and then thanks to the to a new
algorithm we were able to segment the
tissue
into two more but also into
tls
so this this approach will be used to uh
to evaluate the association of image
analysis
based detection of tls and the
pathologist based detection of tls as to
have an easy to implement tool
to detect teles in
in the clinical setting and routine
so from this study some some
information i want to uh to
give you is at the presence but it was
quite evident that the presence of
mature tls is a predictive
of response we mean checkpoint inhibitor
so besides the
the the use of the as
of the detection of tls
as a possible biomarker it strengthens
the fact that b cells play a critical
role in in response to immune checkpoint
inhibitor
and the use of this biomarker can allow
a proper selection of patients
that might respond to cancer immuno
immunotherapy and so that it's something
that
must be
evaluated in uh in a prospective a
clinical clinical trial
and finally
besides pathologist assessments
of tls so image analysis could be
also an additional tool to simplify the
process of tls
of tls detection and this is an approach
which is under investigation
so finally just i wanted to to to thank
all the the
the people who were involved in this uh
project and particularly antoine
italiano from st to bergany who was a
coordinator of this work with francois
lewane and all the bargaining team but
this work was also performed together
with
santo de rocher de carlier and
rv friedman uh teams from gustavosi
and astrazeneca and also from
from xp site
so i will be happy to answer any
questions from your side and
[Music]
thank you very much for your attention
thank you alban for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
is tls within the sample considered or
only when within or closed to the tumor
so thank you for
for asking this question
um
so no it's important to consider only
only tls when
there are within the tumor lesion or at
least
close to the invasive margin and so we
defined a cutoff
around one millimeter
[Music]
far from the invasive invasive margin so
this is the first
geographical aspect of the tls
positivity consideration but there is
another point that must be considered is
also the number of
of cells within the tls so at least
50 cells
50 cells that should should
[Music]
be within this this structure so either
b or t cells but
at least the minimal size of the of the
tls
okay thank you
next question
how were the images captured
so yes
the image were captured thanks to the
multispectral imaging platform from from
aquarius so the polaris
polaris system and
so first of course
there is a technical advantage uh this
is a multi-spectral imaging platform but
another aspect that you you can also
capture from this presentation is that
we
we performed uh staining on lots of
on a large number of samples and this
this
equipment is compatible with uh with
high
not high footprint but
important throughput screening
approach so it's not uh
so it was really a big advantage to have
this platform
for this for this work okay great
next question
did you compare cd8 density obtained by
image analysis with a score from a
pathologist
yes so thank you for the question yes
it's um
it's a point that we evaluated
because for up to now the the cd8 and
filtration uh in at least in
in clinical routine is mostly evaluated
by pathologists with a basic score so
highly infiltrated moderately
infiltrated so
there is a score but with a limited
i would say
with a number of uh of score and so we
uh but still we compare this scoring
with uh with a density obtained by by
image analysis and we obtain a good
correlation so meaning that the image
approach immediately this approach is
quite robust
thank you
next question
do you think that the image analysis can
be supportive for tls detection and
scoring
yes uh we believe so this work is uh
currently uh under
an investigation so we need to to
wait for the for the results um
so as mentioned so the important point
is that we we can consider a tls
only when
within the the tumor the tumor lesion or
at least close
so it ideally it would be nice to have a
tumor marker to help the
tls detection
within this this tumor area
but without it
it would be probably helpful to have
validation by a pathologist so
again it's it's an evaluation that we
are currently
currently doing
more soon hopefully
okay thank you next question
in my current setting i have a standard
fluorescent scanner and i'm limited to
four dies
did you use a specific cube's
combination to image seven dies would it
be possible to know which imaging
platform did you use thank you
yeah um so yes it's just what i
mentioned before yes we use
this multi-spectral imaging uh platform
so the the vector polarity polaris which
allows for seven marker uh
capture
uh so we cannot use a four marker uh i
mean the system that can capture only
four markers
so uh otherwise you need to to
to decrease the number of markers you
want to evaluate
[Music]
yes and so this is also an important
point to mention so we we use
opal dye
to
to reveal each each marker so which we
are compatible with
with the system we were
using
okay
next question
what image analysis software did you use
um we use a system which is provided
with uh with equipment so it's inform
inform software
that can uh that can allow a
very uh
large
type of image image analysis so we can
as i mentioned we can
decompose the tissue
in so i at least the tumor sample within
different regions so tc region tumor
versus non-tumor and then we can we can
use this
cell segmentation for further
phenotyping either by
by machine learning so this is based on
an artificial intelligence but then also
we can use so this is was not used in
the scope of this project but it's
something that we are
using for the project we can use an
approach based only on the
fluorescence intensity analysis so
similar to flow cytometry approach
okay
next question
can you please explain a little as to
how you validated your mif panel
uh yes so it's a two two step uh two
step validation so the first step
we validate each marker uh and this
validation is really uh based on uh on
distribution and exchange with a
pathologist so expert pathologists that
we have the chance to work with at the
institute institute of bargaining
and so once each marker or
are validated they are implemented
both in monoplex and in multiplex and we
evaluate the
thanks to the image analysis approach
the density or the
intensity of each signal
in both situation and as soon as
we have the same the same pattern in
both conditions so monoplex versus
multiplex we consider that the
multiplex is validated
thank you
next question
what criteria did you use to distinguish
between cd8 high versus cd8 low how did
you decide on the criteria
yes it's a very interesting question
so in this work we decided to use a
conventional approach so we use a median
median value
so the
patient with cd8 high
to more where
above the median and the other where
below
it's an approach that we use in some
condition in some work and for the work
we can also make a different cutoff for
example the 25 percent
uh
high patient so i mean patient can be
only considered a high as high when
when superior to
the 24
limit
but yes it's already
a subjective approach
hey great thank you
next question
aside from t cell infiltration do you
have plans to examine the immune spatial
neighborhoods surrounding the mtls
[Music]
so no we didn't look exactly at the at
the tumor microenvironment around
around the tls so we have work uh
currently on going on the evaluation on
the structure of
the exact structure of the of the tlf so
the composition of b cells descends and
t-cells and other cells
for example between responder and
non-responder patient but we didn't look
at the correlation between the
microenvironment around tls
either they are mature or not mature so
yes it's an interesting point that could
be could be addressable
okay great thank you
our next question has
multiple questions embedded um so
hello thanks a lot for your great talk
could you please precise how you chose
your threshold to perform survival
analyses
mature tls versus non-mature tls
also was it easy to adapt your multiplex
panel on several tissues from solid
tumors
and last how was designed your
classifier to automatically detect tls
criteria of staining only or also the
area and thank you very much
okay
yes good good question it's
we didn't consider cutoff for the mature
tls we we consider only the present
versus absence if uh if tumor a sample
had the presence of
of one mature tls it was in the class of
maturity
and of course the opposite was without
mature trs
so it's not a matter of
maturity density for example within the
sample so
no cutoff or no threshold value
the other question about the easy easy
to implement
[Music]
approach for this for this multiplex
considering that it was a punk
pancancer studio
so yes it was
i would not say easy but it was possible
because we had we had the pathologist
working on this
working on this
scoring
because we didn't have a for example a
general
pump cancer pancreas marker so to define
the tumor
tumor tissue versus non-gmo tissue so
this was possible because
pathologists were able to score
this different type of tumor
and last
how was designing your classifier to
automatically detect tls
um
so this point it's quite complicated to
to answer because this is something that
we are currently
doing and i guess
it's based on the
on the size of the of the tls
so this is a machine learning approach
so
it's not a black box but we don't have
all the
all the algorithms detail so it's based
on the on the size and probably also on
the content
of the cells at least you have to to
to
to detect organized b cells and with
some t-cells either
really organized around or within uh
within or mixed with with a b cells so
this point is quite complicated to
again to to answer because we don't have
all the the elements
thank you
thank you
next question
your study focused on primarily b-cell
biomarkers within the mature
tls's but are you also considering
interrogating other dendritic cell
markers
so yes within the
at least within the
within the tls yes we
we consider to look at
additional marker for for dc
but for instance we we use cd21
which is a marker for follicular android
xl
and but it didn't
it didn't give
better results when compared to the
to the
mature b-cells
feature
so it's something that we use but we are
using other technology technology
approach
okay next question
how thick should the slices of the
tissue be in your opinion in order not
to disrupt the whole tls structure
and also is there any correlation
between tls and tumor stroma formation
or vascularization thank you
so in in the in the work uh
that i presented the
thickness of the slide were similar for
all samples it was a 3.5 micrometer
and in that case i'm not sure it's the
optimal
thickness but at least we were able on
this condition to to detect uh to detect
tears
and then
between this and two more stroma
formation and yes so this is a
this is a really a good point because we
know that uh uh for example high
undertelly alves are really important
for the formation of tls but in this
studio we didn't focus on this type of
of
of structure but it should be it should
be considered in the in the near future
but just one important point i think
this this work is now
can be considered as a really
seminal work that demonstrates
that
tls so
as detected thanks to the
immunohistochemistry because the
previous work was really
was really based on the transcription
transcription
transatomic approach so based on the
signature so this work pays away of
the importance of tls in the response to
cancer immunotherapy at for instance
immune checkpoint inhibitor
but
many things
needs to be done now to really
understand how this tls biology is
important for the to control the
anti-tumor response and the point you
raised i think dendritic cells but also
this uh
vasculature
point is uh is something that will be
considered in the near future by our
team but also i'm sure by other
people interested in this in this
structure
great thank you
next question
who made or stained the antibodies akoya
or yourself
[Laughter]
yes this point no it's um
so we use the aqua system to
to detect uh to detect the
the primary antibody but we use
secondary antibody already conjugated
with uh
with opal so i'm not the
technical expert on this point
but
i think it's uh it's based uh on this
technology
i'm
probably someone
from
aquaria can answer this point sorry i'm
not the
expert for that oh that's fine um next
question
can you describe the cancer types and
stage for the patients in the training
and validation cohorts
so the cancer type it's a pancreas study
so a solid tumor first and carcinoma
so with the
with the majority of lung lung cancer of
course because it's where they check
point in vito or
or used in routine and it was advanced
disease for for all cases
next question
what types of cancer have been
investigated in your studies was the
prevalence of tls similar in different
cancer subtypes
so yes it's again a pancreas study
and so different type of different type
of cancer and yes we we observed a
difference between between the
indication but it was not a massive
difference the general trend was a 30
percent of patients having a detectable
tls
thanks to the immunohistochemistry and
or immunoactive fluorescence approach
but of course we need to to investigate
more in depth the the
this percentage according to the cancer
indication
using larger and larger cohorts sorry
so it looks like we have time for one
more question
did you ever look at tumor micro
environment markers
yes we so
we look at
at a different
different marker it was not included in
this
in this in this work and the analysis is
currently uh is currently ongoing
uh as in this work we focus mostly on
the on the marker within the tls not
not outside
okay well thank you again alvin for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor akoya biosciences for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye